Aujourd'hui je veux vous parler du SIDA en Afrique sub-saharienne.
Vous êtes un public averti,
donc j'imagine que vous savez pas mal de choses sur le SIDA.
Vous savez probablement qu'environ 25 millions d'Africains
sont touchés par le virus, et que le SIDA est une maladie de la pauvreté.
Et qu'en sortant l'Afrique de la pauvreté, nous pourrions y réduire le SIDA.
Si vous en savez un peu plus, vous savez probablement que l'Ouganda, à ce jour,
est le seul pays d'Afrique sub-saharienne
qui ait réussi à combattre l'épidémie,
en utilisant une campagne qui encourageait les gens à l'abstinence, à la fidélité et à l'utilisation du préservatif --
la campagne ABC en anglais. Dans les années 1990 leur taux d'infection a baissé
d'environ 15% de la population à 6% en quelques années seulement.
Si vous suivez un peu la politique, vous savez probablement qu'il y a quelques années
le président a promis de donner 15 milliards de dollars sur 5 ans pour combattre l'épidémie,
et qu'une part importante de cet argent va à des programmes qui suivent l'exemple de l'Ouganda
et changent les comportements pour encourager la population et ainsi réduire l'épidémie.
Aujourd'hui je vais donc parler de certaines choses
que vous ne savez peut-être pas à propos de l'épidémie.
Puis je vais remettre en question
certaines des choses que vous pensez savoir.
Et pour ce faire, je vais vous parler de mes recherches sur l'épidémie
en tant qu'économiste
Je ne vais pas vraiment parler beaucoup d'économie.
Je ne vais pas vous parler d'exportations et de prix.
Mais je vais utiliser des outils et des idées que les économistes connaissent bien
pour réfléchir à un problème qui est plus traditionnellement
vu sous l'angle de la santé publique et de l'épidémiologie
Je pense que cela s'inscrit bien dans l'idée de transversalité.
J'utilise les outils d'une discipline académique
pour réfléchir à un problème d'une autre discipline.
Tout d'abord, nous pensons que le SIDA est un problème de politique.
Il est probable que la plupart d'entre vous ici y pensent en ces termes.
Mais dans cette présentation nous allons essayer de parler de faits.
Nous allons penser à comment l'épidémie évolue et comment les gens y répondent.
Il va peut-être vous paraître que je laisse de côté les politiques publiques,
qui sont les plus importantes,
mais j'espère qu'à la fin de cette présentation vous conclurez
qu'il est en fait impossible de développer une politique efficace
si on ne comprend pas comment l'épidémie fonctionne.
La première chose dont je voudrais parler,
la première chose que nous devons comprendre, c'est
"Comment les gens répondent-ils à l'épidémie?"
Le SIDA est une infection sexuellement transmissible, et le SIDA tue.
Donc dans les lieux où le SIDA est très présent,
le coût des relations sexuelles est très élevé.
Si vous êtes un homme non-porteur au Botswana, où le taux de VIH est de 30%,
si vous avez plus d'une partenaire cette année -- votre conjoint, une copine ou une maîtresse --
votre chance de mourir dans les 10 ans augmente de 3%.
C'est énorme.
Alors il nous semble que les gens devraient avoir moins de relations sexuelles.
En fait, les homosexuels aux États-Unis
ont adopté ce type de comportement dans les années 80.
En étudiant cette population à haut risque, si on leur demande,
"Avez-vous eu plus d'un rapport non protégé dans les deux derniers mois?"
Entre 84 et 88, les "Oui" tombent de 85 à 55%.
C'est un changement considérable en très peu de temps.
Rien de tel ne s'est passé en Afrique.
Les données que nous avons ne sont pas aussi bonnes, mais vous pouvez voir ici
la proportion d'hommes célibataires ayant des rapports sexuels avant le mariage,
ou d'hommes mariés ayant des rapports extra-conjugaux,
et leur évolution du début à la fin des années 90,
et de la fin des années 90 au début des années 2000. L'épidémie s'étend.
Les gens en savent plus sur l'épidémie...
mais les comportements sexuels changent peu.
La baisse est très limitée -- 2 points --
Ça semble étonnant, mais en fait ça ne devrait pas nous surprendre.
Pour comprendre pourquoi, il faut penser à la santé
comme les économistes -- la santé est un investissement.
Si vous êtes un ingénieur informatique et que vous essayez
d'ajouter une nouvelle fonction à votre programme,
vous devez aussi penser à combien cela va coûter.
Vous devez penser à combien cela va rapporter.
Cela va dépendre entre autres
de la durée de vie du programme.
Si la version 10 est sur le point de sortir,
ça ne sert à rien d'ajouter des fonctions dans la version 9.
Les décisions en termes de santé publique sont identiques.
Chaque fois que vous mangez une carotte plutôt qu'un biscuit,
chaque fois que vous allez faire du sport plutôt qu'au cinéma,
vous investissez dans votre santé.
Mais la taille de votre investissement dépend
du nombre d'années qu'il vous reste à vivre -- selon vous
même si vous ne faites pas ces investissements.
C'est pareil pour le SIDA. Éviter d'attraper le SIDA coûte cher.
Les gens aiment avoir des rapports sexuels.
Ça vous apporte quelque-chose en termes de longévité.
Mais l'espérance de vie en Afrique, même sans le SIDA, est vraiment, vraiment basse:
40 ou 50 ans dans beaucoup d'endroits.
Je pense qu'il est possible, quand on pense en ces termes,
que cela explique pourquoi le SIDA a si peu changé les comportements.
Alors testons notre hypothèse.
Pour ça, on peut regarder différentes régions d'Afrique:
est-ce que les peuples où l'espérance de vie est plus élevée changent leur comportement sexuel davantage?
Pour voir si c'est le cas,
je vais regarder des régions où la malaria est présente à différents niveaux.
La malaria tue.
Elle tue beaucoup d'adultes en Afrique, et aussi beaucoup d'enfants.
Ceux qui vivent dans des régions où la malaria est très présente
ont une espérance de vie moindre que ceux qui vivent là où elle est moins présente.
Pour confirmer que
les comportements changent en fonction de l'espérance de vie
on va donc voir si les comportements changent davantage
dans les endroits où la malaria est moins présente.
C'est ce que montre ce graphique.
Il montre, selon le degré de malaria (bas, moyen, élevé)
comment évolue le nombre de partenaires sexuels à mesure qu'augmente la présence du VIH.
Regardez cette courbe bleue,
les endroits avec peu de malaria. Vous voyez
que le nombre de partenaires sexuels baisse beaucoup
à mesure que le VIH augmente.
Là où la présence de la malaria est moyenne, ça baisse un peu
mais pas autant. Là où la malaria est très présente,
ça augmente un peu, mais pas de manière significative.
Ça n'est pas vrai que pour la malaria.
Les jeunes femmes vivant dans des lieux où la mortalité maternelle est élevée
changent moins leur comportement avec le VIH
que celles vivant dans des lieux où la mortalité maternelle est basse.
Il y a un autre risque, et elles répondent moins à ce risque existant.
Cela nous en dit long sur le comportement des gens.
Ça nous explique pourquoi les comportements changent peu en Afrique.
Mais ça nous apprend aussi quelque-chose sur les politiques de santé publique.
Si vous vous préoccupez uniquement du SIDA en Afrique,
il serait bon de lutter aussi contre la malaria,
d'améliorer la qualité de l'air dans les maisons,
et de diminuer le taux de mortalité maternelle.
Car en améliorant tout cela,
vous incitez davantage les gens à éviter le SIDA d'eux-mêmes.
Ça nous apprend aussi quelque chose sur ce que nous évoquions précédemment.
Les campagnes de sensibilisation, comme celle que le Président a lancée,
ne suffisent pas. En tout cas pas toutes seules.
Si l'on n'incite pas les gens à éviter le SIDA d'eux-mêmes,
même s'ils savent tout sur la maladie,
ils risquent quand même de ne pas changer leur comportement.
L'autre chose qu'on apprend ici, c'est que le SIDA ne va pas être vaincu tout seul.
Les gens ne changent pas suffisamment leurs comportements
pour faire baisser la croissance de l'épidémie.
Donc il nous faut penser aux politiques publiques.
Quelles politiques peuvent être efficaces?
Une bonne façon de voir ça est de regarder à ce qui a fonctionné par le passé.
La raison pour laquelle nous savons que la campagne ABC
a fonctionné en Ouganda, est que nous y avons des données sur l'évolution du taux de VIH.
En Ouganda, nous avons vu ce taux baisser.
Nous savons qu'il y a eu cette campagne. C'est comme ça qu'on sait ce qui marche.
Mais ça n'est pas le seul endroit où il y a eu des interventions.
Ailleurs on a essayé des choses, alors pourquoi ne pas regarder
l'évolution du taux de présence du VIH ailleurs?
Malheureusement, il n'y a presque pas de bonnes données
sur le taux de VIH en Afrique avant 2003.
Si je vous demandais: "Donnez-moi
le taux de VIH au Burkina Faso en 1991."
Vous iriez sur Google, et vous apprendriez
qu'en 1991, les seules personnes dépistées au Burkina Faso
étaient les personnes ayant une MST et les femmes enceintes.
Ce qui ne constitue pas un panel très représentatif.
En cherchant davantage,
vous trouveriez qu'en fait 1991 était une assez bonne année.
Parce que, certaines années, seuls les drogués par intraveineuse ont été dépistés.
Mais pire encore -- certaines années c'est seulement ces drogués
d'autres années seulement les femmes enceintes.
Nous n'avons donc aucun moyen de comprendre ce qui s'est passé sur la durée.
Les dépistages ne sont pas cohérents.
Ces dernières années, nous avons eu de bons dépistages.
Au Kenya, en Zambie, dans pas mal de pays,
le dépistage a été effectué au hasard dans la population.
Nous avons donc un grand trou dans notre connaissance.
Je peux vous dire le taux d'infection du VIH au Kenya en 2003,
mais je ne peux rien vous dire sur 1993 ou 1983.
C'est un problème pour élaborer une politique et ça m'a posé problème aussi.
Alors je me suis demandée : comment pouvons-nous obtenir
le taux d'infection du VIH en Afrique dans le passé?
On peut regarder les chiffres de la mortalité,
pour trouver quel était le taux passé d'infection du VIH.
Pour ce faire, il nous faut nous baser sur le fait
que le SIDA est une maladie très particulière.
Le SIDA tue les gens dans la fleur de l'âge.
Peu de maladies ont cette particularité. Vous voyez ici
un graphique du taux de mortalité au Botswana et en Égypte.
Au Botswana il y a beaucoup de cas de SIDA,
en Égypte il y en a peu.
Les taux de mortalité y sont similaires chez les jeunes et les personnes âgées.
Cela sous-entend donc des niveaux de développement similaires.
Mais au milieu, entre 20 et 45 ans,
les taux de mortalité au Botswana sont beaucoup beaucoup plus élevés qu'en Égypte.
Comme peu d'autres maladies tuent les gens,
cette mortalité vient du VIH.
Mias comme les gens morts du SIDA l'ont contracté quelques années plus tôt,
on peut utiliser ces chiffres pour trouver le taux passé d'infection du VIH.
En utilisant cette technique,
l'estimation de ce taux est très proche
des taux obtenus lors de dépistages au hasard dans la population --
mais ils sont très différents des chiffres d'ONUSIDA.
Voici un graphique du taux estimé par ONUSIDA,
et du taux basé sur les taux de mortalité
pour la fin des années 90 dans neuf pays d'Afrique.
Vous voyez que presque sans exception,
les estimations d'ONUSIDA sont plus élevées que nos estimations.
ONUSIDA nous dit que le taux de VIH en Zambie est de 20%
le taux de mortalité montre qu'il n'est que de 5%.
Ce n'est pas rien comme différence.
En d'autres termes:
si le taux d'infection était aussi élevé que le dit ONUSIDA,
il y aurait 60 morts pour 10000 habitants
plutôt que 20 morts pour 10000 dans cette tranche d'âge.
Dans un instant je vais vous montrer
que ces informations nous apprennent quelque chose
sur notre façon de penser le monde.
Elles nous montrent aussi qu'un des faits
dont je parlais au début n'est pas complètement vrai.
Pour ONUSIDA 25 millions de personnes sont infectées,
mais si vous pensez que les chiffres d'ONUSIDA sont bien trop élevés,
peut-être que c'est plutôt 10 ou 15 millions.
Ça ne veut pas dire que le SIDA n'est pas un problème. C'est un énorme problème.
Mais ça sous-tend que ce nombre est peut-être un peu élevé.
Ce que je veux faire, c'est utiliser ces nouveaux chiffres
pour comprendre comment l'épidémie accélère ou ralentit.
Au début je vous disais que je ne vous parlerais pas d'exportations.
Au début de ce projet,
je ne pensais pas du tout à l'économie,
mais au final ça finit toujours pas vous rattraper.
Je vais donc quand même vous parler d'exportations et de prix,
et de la relation entre activité économique,
en particulier volumes d'exportations, et taux de VIH.
En tant qu'économiste, je sais bien entendu
que le développement, l'ouverture des échanges
sont bons pour les pays en développement.
Ça aide à améliorer le niveau de vie des gens.
Mais l'ouverture et l'interconnexion ont un coût
en termes de maladies. Ce n'est pas une surprise.
Ce mercredi, la journaliste Laurie Garrett m'a annoncé
que j'allais avoir la grippe aviaire,
et que ça ne serait pas le cas du tout
si nous n'avions aucun contact avec l'Asie.
Le VIH est très lié aux mouvements.
C'est un steward sur une compagnie
aérienne qui l'a introduit aux États-Unis.
Il avait contracté la maladie en Afrique et l'a rapportée.
C'est ainsi qu'a commencé l'épidémie aux États-Unis.
En Afrique, les épidémiologistes savent depuis longtemps
que les chauffeurs routiers et les émigrés ont plus de chances d'être infectés.
Que les zones à forte activité economique --
avec des routes et de l'urbanisation --
ont des taux d'infection supérieurs aux autres.
Ça ne veut pas dire du tout
qu'en exportant plus, en augmentant les échanges, le taux d'infection augmenterait.
Ces nouvelles données, le taux d'infection sur plusieurs années,
nous permettent de tester cette hypothèse. Et il semble bien --
heureusement --
que ces deux variables soient effectivement corrélées.
Plus d'exportations = plus de SIDA. La corrélation est très grande.
D'après mes données, si vous doublez les exportations,
le nombre de nouvelles infections au VIH quadruplent.
Cela a des conséquences en termes de prévisions et de politiques publiques.
En termes de prévisions, si le commerce est sur le point de changer,
par exemple en raison de la loi américaine pour la Croissance en Afrique,
ou en raison d'autres politiques qui encouragent le commerce,
on peut prédire quelles zones ont plus de chances d'être très infectées par le VIH.
C'est là-bas qu'on peut essayer de mettre en place des mesures préventives.
De même, en développant des politiques d'encouragement des exportations,
en connaissant cet effet --
ce qui arrive quand on augmente les exportations --
on peut mieux réfléchir aux bonnes politiques à suivre.
On apprend donc quelque-chose sur ce qu'on pensait savoir.
Bien que la pauvreté soit liée au SIDA,
dans le sens où l'Afrique est pauvre et le SIDA y est très présent,
ça n'est pas forcément en diminuant la pauvreté -- en tout cas à court terme --
en augmentant les exportations et le développement,
que cela va entraîner
une baisse du taux d'infection au VIH.
Pendant cette présentation, j'ai mentionné plusieurs fois
le cas de l'Ouganda, et le fait
que c'est le seul pays d'Afrique sub-saharienne à avoir eu des succès.
Cela a été crié haut et fort.
Cela a été répliqué au Kenya, en Tanzanie, en Afrique du Sud et dans bien d'autres lieux.
Mais je veux remettre ça en question.
Il y a bien eu une baisse du taux d'infection
en Ouganda dans les années 90. Il y a bien eu une campagne d'éducation.
Mais il y a eu quelque chose d'autre en Ouganda à cette époque.
Il y a eu une forte baisse des prix du café.
Le café est la première source d'exportatrions de l'Ouganda.
Ces exportations ont chuté au début des années 90 -- un déclin qui coïncide
de très près avec la baisse des nouvelles infections au VIH.
Ces deux séries --
la courbe noire qui est celle des exportations en valeur, et la rouge qui est celle des infections --
augmentent toutes les deux.
Vers 1987, elles commencent à beaucoup baisser.
Et elles continuent à se suivre
en augmentant légèrement, plus tard dans la décennie.
En combinant l'intuition et ce chiffre
aux données dont je vous parlais plus tôt,
vous voyez qu'entre 25% et 50%
du déclin du taux d'infection en Ouganda
aurait eu lieu sans la campagne d'éducation.
C'est extrêmement important en termes de politiques publiques.
Nous dépensons trop d'argent à répliquer cette campagne,
et si elle n'est que 50% aussi efficace qu'on le pensait,
alors il y a plein d'autre choses
dans lesquelles nous pourrions mettre notre argent à la place.
En traitant les autres MST pour baisser les taux de transmission.
En lançant des campagnes de circoncision pour baisser ces taux.
Et on peut penser à plein d'autres choses.
Cela nous montre qu'il faudrait peut-être qu'on y pense davantage.
J'espère qu'en 16 minutes je vous ai dit des choses que vous ne saviez pas sur le SIDA,
et j'espère que vous remettez davantage en question
ce que vous saviez.
J'espère vous avoir convaincus
qu'il est important de comprendre ces choses sur l'épidémie,
afin de réfléchir aux politiques publiques.
Plus que tout, vous savez, je suis une chercheuse.
Et quand je partirai d'ici, je retournerai
dans mon petit bureau, avec mon ordi et mes chiffres --
et ce qu'il y a de vraiment génial
c'est qu'à chaque fois que je pense à la recherche, il y a plus de questions.
Il y a plus de choses que je veux faire.
Et ce qui est vraiment, vraiment génial ici
c'est que je suis sûr que les questions que VOUS vous posez
sont très différentes des questions que JE me pose.
Et j'ai hâte d'entendre ce qu'elles sont.
Alors merci beaucoup.